je fais un métier saugrenue je suis me
remets colog c'est-à-dire spécialiste
des fourmis lorsqu'on travaille sur les
fourmis ont fait face à deux questions
récurrentes
la première comment on s'en débarrasse
je reçois énormément d'hiver qui
commencent par bonjour docteur j'ai des
fourmis plein ma cuisine je sais plus
quoi faire j'ai mis du javel j'ai mis du
poison des remèdes de grand-mère rien à
y faire elle revient alors là moi je
réponds quand j'ai des fourmis dans la
cuisine je les aspirants lieu dans des
petites boîtes et je les étudie je ne
sais pas du tout comment s'en débarrasse
la deuxième question que l'on me pose
c'est c'est quoi on m'envoie les photos
est souvent il ya deux pics à aider et
on me dit j'ai trouvé ça dans mon jardin
c'est quoi alors là ma première réponse
on croyait réflexes et c'est flou donc
là il ya une petite mise au point qui
s'impose autant tivoli terral que
figurer dans le groupe des hominidés
il y a huit espèces différentes c'est
notre groupe
alors s'il est facile de faire la
différence entre un gorille est un
humain la plupart du temps chez les
fourmis
c'est une autre histoire chez les
fourmis il existe treize mille espèces
identifiées 25000 estimé pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée c'est 1500
espèces de mammifères du hamster à la
baleine des fourmis il en existe de
toutes les couleurs de toutes les formes
des poilus des qui piquent et qui
mordent il en existe aussi de toutes les
tailles
certaines familles font 40 fois la
taille d'autres fourmis si parfois il
est facile de les différencier par set
parce que certaines ressemblent à des
bus bisounours et d'autres sont mis
scorpions me fourmies et remy scorpions
derrière des fois c'est bien plus
difficile
il vous faudra parfois compter le nombre
de poils autour de l'anus de la fourmi
pour différencier deux espèces véridique
les fourmis sont sur la terre depuis 170
millions d'années elles ont foulé les
mêmes prairies que les dinosaures mais
elles n'ont pas subi la crise du crétacé
elles sont toujours là et bien là
des fourmis y en a partout sur tous les
continents sauf en antarctique mais il
faut les comprendre
puma est pas super hospitalier on est
sept milliards d'humains
il ya des millions de milliards de
fourmis des quadrillions c'est simple
prenez tous les humains vous les mettez
sur une balance de l'autre côté vous
mettez toutes les fourmis vous aurez
approximativement la même biomasse bien
qu'on est en train de gagner cette
compétition
pas parce qu'on est plus nombreux mais
parce qu'individuellement on a un petit
peu grossi
les fourmis elles vivent en société
et souvent on les compare aux sociétés
humaines mais en réalité les fourmis ne
vivent pas en société
elles vivent en famille et l'histoire de
famille des fourmis c'est plutôt un
croisement entre santa barbara et game
of thrones que la petite maison dans la
prairie
laissez moi vous raconter cette histoire
cela commence avec une rêve souvent à
l'ailé
vous appelez ça les fourmis volantes
elle sort au printemps elle part à la
recherche d'un mal la plupart du temps
le mal est beaucoup plus petit il ya des
énormes mieux pour des pour repérer la
femelle en vol lui on le compare plutôt
à des moucherons
je vous ai dit treize mille espèces donc
forcément on a des exceptions il ya
certaines femelles qui préfèrent se
passer de mal
elles partent à pied et elles font du
clonage elle s'auto engendre d'autres
femelles eux par contre vont préférer
avoir plusieurs mâles
et parfois en même temps
il faut savoir que la reine ne
s'accouplent aura qu'une seule fois dans
sa vie autant en profiter
là où il n'y a pas d'exception
c'est sur le sort des mâles il meurt
après l'accouplement pour plusieurs
raisons soit ils meurent de faim soit
ils se font picorer par les oiseaux
soit ils laissent leur pénis avec un
petit bout d'intestin à l'intérieur de
la femelle pour faire bouchons pour
éviter que d'autres mâles visite cette
même femelle un petit peu possessif le
mâle fournit la fourmi une fois féconde
et enlève ses ailes puisque de toute
façon elle sortira plus est elles
forment sa fourmilière elle commence à
pondre des oeufs alors elle peut faire
ça tout seul ou avec des copines des
soeurs et les fois l'emporter cordiale
parfois beaucoup moins
il y en a une qui prend la dominance et
elle assassine ses soeurs les eu des
fourmis peuvent donner différents types
d'individus ils peuvent donner des mâles
à nouveau les rênes à nouveau et des
ouvrières ce sont des femelles qui sont
la plupart du temps stériles soit
morphologiquement parce qu'elles n'ont
pas d'ovaires soit fonctionnellement
parce qu'on leur tape dessus pour pas
qu'elle fonde au bout d'un moment on a
une grande famille où on a un petit peu
des mâles un petit peu des reines au
printemps mais la plupart du temps on a
beaucoup d'ouvrières sont des petites
familles de quelques millions
d'individus
alors il ya une reine dont il faut
parler c'est la reine des fourmis cela
va juste alors allez un petit problème
avec très très grande mandibule et du
coup les pas très doué pour s'occuper de
ses oeufs
c'est un peu le tour aux mains d'argent
des fourmis donc elle a trouvé une
solution
elle part à la recherche d'un nid déjà
pré établis la plupart du temps d'une
autre espèce
elle rentre dans la colonie façon ninja
elle masque son odeur elle va jusqu'à la
chambre royale et la ldk pitt la reine
elle se roule contre son cadavre pour
prendre son odeur et les fourmis
résidente n'y verront que du feu
elles vont élever la descendance de
cette reine qui n'a rien à voir avec les
fourmis sont souvent victimes
d'anthropomorphisme et cela donne lieu à
des rumeurs
la première rumeur la reine c'est la
patronne faut la reine c'est pas la
reine d'angleterre
c'est une pondeuses record de ponte chez
la fourmi légionnaires qui pond un oeuf
à la seconde elle va engendrer dans
toute une vie
300 millions de descendants c'est la
population des états unis
une fourmi comment fêter le cirque plume
une seule fois et bien là lui
spermathèque une petite poche à stern où
elle garde le sperme à température
ambiante pendant cinq à dix ans qu'elle
utilise quand elle en a besoin pas
besoin d'écrire stache iphone deuxième
rumeur soldats qui protègent la colonie
sont des femelles faux e c'est ce sont
des mâles part dans la rue lorsque ce
qu'on est mal ce sont des femelles en
réalité voilà je suis toujours victime
d'anthropomorphisme aussi en réalité sur
cette photo au centre vous voyez un mal
c'est le petit organisme chétif ici
entouré de ses soeurs
[Applaudissements]
il faut savoir que le mal n'a qu'une
fonction dans la colonie se reproduire
il n'est pas capable d'obtenir sa
nourriture il n'est pas capable de se
protéger
il dépend de ses soeurs ses soeurs par
contre peuvent avoir toutes les tailles
donc ici vous voyez des soeurs donc
l'adage mange ta soupe tu grandiras est
vrai celle et fournit donc ici c'est
deux soeurs que vous voyez donc c'est un
peu comme si ma soeur faisait 15 mètres
de haut et le poids d'une baleine à
bosse pas sûr que je l'inviterai à dîner
tous les soirs troisième rumeurs et
celle là on la doit à la fontaine la
fourmi travailleuse faut des fourmis qui
font rien de la journée
mais alors rien du tout 10 à 30% de la
colonie lcl sont là au cas où
or il faut savoir que le travail dans
une colonie de fourmis est organisée
c'est ce qu'on appelle la division du
travail donc il ya différentes fonctions
dans une colonie chez les fourmis pot de
miel par exemple certaines fourmis son
frigo vivent donc elle s'accroche au
plafond de la colonie elle stocke la
nourriture pour les autres elles vont
régurgiter cette nourriture dans un
bouche à bouche avec leurs congénères
cela peut paraître un petit peu
dégoûtant ayons une pensée pour les
termites qui reçoivent leur nourriture
d'un orifice bien moins fréquentables
certainement autres fourmis les fourmis
tortues ont une fonction essentielle à
la colonie elles font porte
leurs têtes fait exactement le diamètre
de l'entrée de la colonie
elle se vit cela et faire une la colonie
d'autres colonies va un couvre les
nids-de-poule sur la route c'est une
fonction comme une autre
d'autres sont tapés ta bouche alors
celle-ci en fait il ya des mouches qui
essayent de pondre des oeufs dans la
tête des fourmis qui ramène la
nourriture donc élire petite soeur qui
monte en haut et qui chasse les mouches
d'autres fourmis son médecin parce que
sur les champs de bataille défense fait
couper une jambe ou deux donc la fourmi
médecin vient lécher les peler et mes
lentilles sceptique parce qu'une fourmi
peut mourir d'une infection mais elle
peut très bien vivre avec une jambe ou
deux ans mais certaines fourmis anton
destin un petit peu plus triste
ce sont les vigiles chez la fourmi forêt
luce par exemple il est impossible de
fermer le nid de l'intérieur parce que
le sol est trop sablonneux donc il va y
avoir deux ou trois fournit chaque soir
vont fermer le nier se sacrifier parce
que ces fourmis ne passeront pas la nuit
parce qu'elles vont se faire prêter ce
qui m'intéresse plus particulièrement à
moi c'est ce que font les fourmis en
équipe
il faut savoir que les fourmis sont
capables de faire en groupe
ce qu'elles ne sont pas capables de
faire individuellement comme ici
transporter une croix qui fait 100 fois
leur taille
certaines fourmis en groupe sont
beaucoup plus violente c'est le cas des
fourmis tortionnaires or celle-ci et
construisent un piège d'une sorte de
maillage en association avec un
champignon bien construit ce maillage
sur les tiges et là les insectes se pose
ce qu'ils font ils sont cachés et au
moment où l'insecte se posent elles
sortent par les petits trous attrapé
pâte coince l'insecte et la sorte tout
et le coupe façon sushis
d'autres fourmis sont un petit peu moins
violentes elles sont comme on pourrait
appeler des bergères elle élève des
pucerons
c'est un peu dommage pour vos rosiers
car elle protège ces pucerons contre les
prédateurs et aussi contre les
intempéries parce qu'elles peuvent les
rendre et la colonie le soir en réalité
entre ces pucerons venons trait les
vaches pour obtenir du miellat
extrêmement nutritifs et si parfois
elles sont un petit peu à femme elle
peut avoir mangé un ou deux aussi
d'autres fourmis sont plutôt
végétarienne téléphonique au poste de
feuilles elles sont surtout agricultrice
ces fourmis ramasse du feuillage il faut
savoir qu'elles peuvent décimer un arbre
en une seule journée
une colonie alors pourquoi ramener les
feuilles elles les mange pas en réalité
elles vivent en association avec un
champignon qui lui mangent les feuilles
et en échange contre ses feuilles
il donne des petites excroissances très
nutritive aux fourmis
le problème de ce champignon c'est
qu'ils attrapent des maladies mais la
fourmi a pensé à tout vous voyez sur son
thorax ici elle a des taches blanches ce
sont des bactéries
ces bactéries produisent des
antibiotiques que les fourmis vont
utiliser et enduire sur le champignon
pour le protéger des infections
ces fourmis la découvre l'agriculture il
ya 50 millions d'années l'humain il ya
dix mille ans l'antibiotique et des
millions d'années et nous y à peu près
moins de cent ans
les fourmis sont d'excellents
architectes en groupe
ici vous voyez un monticule mais sous ce
monticule se cache un nid de la taille
d'un appartement 4 pièces il contient
huit mille chambres toutes reliées par
des autoroutes et sony et ventilés grâce
à des petites cheminée qu'elle
construise qu'elle oriente en fonction
de la direction du vent pour faire
rentrer l'oxygène dans la colonie et
fait ressortir le dioxyde de carbone
elles vont pouvoir entièrement contrôlée
l'hygrométrie du nid les fourmis sont
résiliente
elles savent se sauver face à des
intempéries donc n'essayez pas avec un
tuyau d'arrosage de noyer vos fourmies
ça ne sert à rien
elle s'affaire des radeaux
alors comment ça marche parce que
j'irais bien ses ouailles évidemment en
réalité les échanges de position c'est
comme un tapis roulant
c'est un petit peu à quoi un coup à toi
un coup à moi avant de plonger elles
prennent une petite bulle d'air entre la
tête et le thorax et le plonge
elle passe sous leurs ados et elles
remontent elles peuvent vivre sur ses
radeaux plusieurs semaines au bout d'un
moment forcément la nourriture commence
à manquer il faut se débarrasser des
choses qui ne servent à rien donc les
mâles sont jetés par dessus bord
dès les premiers là où les fourmis
excellent c'est le trafic
il n'y a pas d'embouteillage et fourmies
quel est leur secret ça fait 15 ans
qu'on travaille dessus en jeu construit
des autoroutes à fourmies dans mon
laboratoire et je compte des fourmis et
j'essaye de comprendre comment elles
quand elles sont 25 centimètres carrés
elle court et nous quand on est
l'équivalent salir huit piétons dans un
petit mètre carré en écoutant le secret
c'est qu'elles n'ont pas de règles il
n'y a pas de règles préétablies schl et
fournit la fourmi réagi au niveau local
à son plus proche voisin
c'est comme si les feux de circulation
le nombre de voix le sens de la
circulation s'adapter en temps réel à
l'intensité du trafic ça serait génial
non cela a inspiré la robotique la
robotique en essaim faire de petits
robots peu coûteux qui individuellement
savent rien faire mais qui en groupe
peuvent résoudre des problèmes
extrêmement complexe cette approche de
la robotique est complémentaire à une
approche différente un peu plus
traditionnel qui est d'investir dans un
robot extrêmement coûteux et qui s'est
normalement faire plus de choses
le secret derrière le succès des fourmis
en cinq mots coopération altruisme
résilience auto-organisation sacrifice
chez les fourmis c'est pas le plus fort
c'est pas le plus puissant qui décide
chez les fourmis c'est pas la taille qui
compte c'est le nombre
[Applaudissements]